abigail is with us in dallas texas i
Abigail how are you I'm doing good how
are you mr. Anthony better than I
deserve
what's up I was calling because I needed
some assistance in trying to decide how
to get out of step
I am currently it's really embarrassing
but I have 429,000 didn't loan that good
are you a lawyer
unfortunately neither I am a pharmacist
so I don't know if that really I am four
hundred grand to become a pharmacist
yeah well it was actually a private
school and the interest from because I
graduated five years ago in the interest
7-point I think it's like seven point
two five so what are you making like 120
hundred and thirty currently is 120 and
then my husband makes ninety so together
we make 210 on the for taxes and
unfortunately before I found your
program I we purchased the home that
right now I know we shouldn't have
because we can't afford it but we
currently owe three hundred and fifty
thousand on that 3100 what's your worth
right now it's worth four it's estimated
425 ok so you didn't put anything around
it
do you have any money saved I was out of
work for a while but we only have about
30 thousand saved right now because I
was out of work for about a year I had a
baby mom so I couldn't work for a while
but we only have thirty thousand in our
savings and right now we are both
working full-time
so we're estimating to make about 210
but for the year yeah and I was just
trying to figure out which loan how to
really if I should refine that the
student loans for you know lower rate or
just pay off the house and then you know
I'm really not sure I don't know
if you were to go to your doctor for a
checkup and you sat down with your
doctor and he said have a go I got
really bad news you got cancer it was it
would scare you to death wouldn't it oh
yeah and then he would say but I think
we can save you if you do these three
things it's going to hurt it's gonna be
really radical but I think we can save
you that's where you are you have
financial cancer the bad news is you are
in a deep hole the good news is you have
a pretty good-sized shovel making 210
but you guys are broke people and you
need to start living like broke people
you've been living for five years like
you make money you don't make money
you are broke and you're gonna have to
do what the cancer doctor says or you're
gonna die okay and that means you are
never going on vacation again until you
get this cleaned up you are not going
out to eat again until you get this
cleaned up you aren't buying anymore XYZ
period beans and rice rice and beans at
your house you're gonna live like broke
people because you're broke people if
you make $210,000 and you do that and
you live on less than a hundred thousand
and you put a hundred thousand dollars a
year on student loans in four years
you'll be debt-free won't you yeah but
that means no life scorched earth on the
lifestyle and that's gonna shock your
system because you guys have been
spending everything you make for five
years you have nothing to show for your
good income you got to stop it it's
gonna be radical and there's no
in-between
this student loan is going to be the
bane of your existence for the next
twenty five freaking years if you don't
stand up to it and punch it in the nose
you have got to get scared enough to get
radical are you oh yes I was so I was
thinking if we
should sell the house it doesn't have
any equity okay I don't know any good to
sell it it's not your problem your
problem is you guys spend everything you
make $30,000 to your name what do you
owe on your cars we don't know we don't
have any credit cards or any card that's
doing this at home was worse oh I got my
car back in 2012 and it's a Hyundai
Sonata and it's already paid off
honestly I don't even know how much it
was yeah what's his car would his car oh
he just bought it it was a old car I
think there's about 5,000 okay all right
so you're not driving you're not driving
fancy cars good all right let's get on a
tight budget on every dollar and the two
of you sit down tonight put the kids to
bed turn off the TV and look deeply into
each other's eyes and say the worm has
turned
we're about to change our lives if
you'll do that I can show you how to
walk out of this but you can no longer
screw around with this it's not going to
just the lone Ranger's not coming the
Calvary is not coming the John Wayne is
not coming he's dead you have to fix
this
you caused the problem and you have the
income to fix it but you're gonna have
to get radical and the more radical you
get the faster you'll get out the deeper
you cut the more money you throw at
these student loans the faster you'll
get out but dancing what the devil has
gotten you nowhere except getting your
toes stepped on and that's what you've
been doing you've been dancing with Oh
ugly Salome just like like she loves you
or something and she does not love you
she wants to ruin your life and is in
the process of it thanks Abigail I hope
that helps you